Let's go.
I did release a course on the Jebaba
London system with my good friend,
Grandmaster Oleksandr Bortnik.
The link to that course will be in the
description to the next few YouTube
videos, including this one, and I'll
redirect you to the video where I kind
of advertise and preview the course
more specifically, so in a couple of
the subsequent games, I did want to
introduce the Jebaba London and show a
couple of cool lines from the course.
So this will be sort of in parallel to
the main speed run recommendation,
which is of course 1E4, we had one
Jebaba London game already, and in that
game I did preview the course, this was
a few games ago, but anyways, let's
focus on the task at hand.
We are facing the move 1G6, and when
you're a D4 player, you have to be
flexible if you want to be a
principled, serious opening player in
the sense that when you face moves like
G6 or D6 or E6, there's no dispute that
the best way to quote unquote punish
these openings is to play principled
chess, right, if you're a London
player, you're a D4, C4 player, you
know, if you want to really fight for
advantages in every game in principled
fashion, then investing some time
studying certain D4, E4 openings is
very much worthwhile, and this doesn't
necessarily make you an E4 player, this
doesn't mean that you, these openings
have nothing to do with the more
mainstream lines like the Sicilian and
the Ruy Lopez, and you can study them
from the white side, even if you're not
too familiar with ideas inherent in 1E4
openings, this I think is a big
misconception, which is that, let's say
you're a London player and you say,
well, if I play E4, I have to know the
ideas that attend to 1E4 openings, not
at all, this is its own thing, and you
can study this as its own thing, you
don't have to be an E4 player to crush
an opening like the modern
consistently, okay, and hopefully this
game is going to show that I am an E4
player, but I'm going to try to show
that these openings are pretty
approachable and you can learn them
without investing 30 hours into, you
know, learning an entire chessable
course or learning a ton of theory,
this is of course the modern, and we
have a wealth of options against the
modern starting from this position
where we can develop either the knight
to f3 or the knight to c3, I've also
previously played the move pawn to c3
in previous speedrun games in order to
take this bishop out of commission, but
let's play principal chess in this
game, let's go knight c3, which is of
course the main move, and it's also the
most flexible move because you reserve
the ability to push the pawn up to f4,
that is the Austrian attack, which is
the most principled way of meeting the
perk, but we're right now facing a
different system, this is called the
Gergenidze system, named after Georgian
grandmaster, Bukhudi Gergenidze, and
this has been around really since the
50s and 60s, Hikaru loves to play this
system with black and blitz games
because it's an easy system to play,
and oftentimes the center gets really
locked up, so if white is unfamiliar
with the main ideas, you can really get
a feeling that this position is still
to play f4, but that's not what we're
going to do, I'm going to introduce you
to a very practical system against the
Gergenidze, which gives white a very
easy position to play, black can
equalize against this system with ultra
-precise play, but it's practical in the
sense that most players, I think under
24, 2300, will probably not be familiar
with the correct pathway and will not
reproduce it to the most precise
extent, what we do here is start with
the move bishop to e3, you can also
start with the move f3, I think bishop
e3 is more flexible, you want to
reserve the pawn moves and delay them
until you absolutely have to play them,
whereas you know that bishop e3 is a
nice developing move as it is, black is
not obliged to play d5, and I would
define the Gergenidze as a cross
between the Karokan and the modern, so
black tries to get the best of all
worlds, and the move bishop e3 is
helpful even if black deviates and goes
d6, and transitions back into like a
perk setup, bishop on e3 is a very,
very good piece, whereas we're not
totally sure that we in fact want to
put the pawn on f3, but now that black
has played d5, we basically are playing
the fantasy variation, my official
recommendation against the Karokan, as
you hopefully know, is the fantasy, so
if you strip away these two minor
pieces and this piece, we actually just
have a fantasy, and it's quite clear
that the moves knight c3 and bishop e3
have not detracted from the
effectiveness of our setup, to the
contrary, that's actually where the
bishop often belongs in the fantasy,
and the knight of course is usually
developed to c3 as well, so there's
only one move, as far as I know, that
allows black to fight for equality, all
other moves give white an excellent
position, and it's easy to lose this
very, very quickly if you're not ultra
accurate with black, a lot of players
just don't have a good sense of where
the pieces belong here, and one of the
biggest draws of the move f3 is that
black experiences problems with their
knight on g8, in the Gurganidze system,
you might have seen like Hikaru and
others bring the knight out to h6, here
this move is not sensible because white
plays queen d2, the f5 square is
protected, that's the key, that's why
we're delaying the move e5, meanwhile
if black plays knight f6, that also
walks into e5, and black has to lose
yet another tempo, shifting the knight
back toward a very awkward square, such
as d7, our opponent counterstrikes in
the center, I will admit that I'm not
familiar with this move, and perhaps
neither is our opponent, but this is a
move which isn't justified from a
general principle standpoint, because
we are the ones with a lead in
development, black is blasting open the
center, which should favor the side
that has more pieces developed, in this
case it's us, and I don't think that we
should overthink it, right, hey our
opponent wants to open up the center, I
am absolutely game, the one thing that
you should notice is that after pawn
takes e5, which I think is what we're
gonna play, I don't see the reason, I
don't particularly see a compelling
reason to take the pawn on d5, we can
do it on the next move, what you should
notice though is after d takes e, black
does not have the move d4, you should
make a mental note to yourself that
these pieces are unforkable squares,
but d4 doesn't work because we have two
defenders on that square, and black is
only one attacker, so I think the best
most flexible way to continue is first
and foremost to take on e5, you want to
open up the center, I'm more than happy
to do that, and if black recaptures
with a bishop, I don't see a reason
that we can't just then take on d5 and
hunt for the extra pawn.
Alternatively, we could focus on
quickly developing our queen side with
queen d2 and long castle in order to
exert more pressure on the d5 pawn,
that leads to some interesting tactical
complications, queen d2 here may seem
to be a blunder due to d4, but if you
look a little bit further in that
position, we can castle queen side and
black can't move the d pawn because the
Queen's gonna hang with checkmate, but
black can support the d pawn by playing
c5, and I'm not totally convinced that
that's the way the way to go, I mean
other than e takes d5, perhaps there's
like bishop to d4, trying to get the
the dark squared bishops off the board
and really underscore the the weakness
of the dark squares on the King's side,
but that just seems a little bit too
fancy, I think that we should start
with a move e takes d5, and depending
on how black responds, we will either
try to solidify our extra material or
we will focus on getting our King out
of the center, because you should
remember that when you play the move
f3, you make rather serious weaknesses
in your center and on your King side,
in particular the bishop on e3 loses
its support, why is that important?
Well if black plays knight f6 and then
castles and puts a rook on e8, we're
gonna have to be really really careful
because that bishop on e3 is gonna get
caught on the crossfire, and the last
thing that you want is a King stuck in
the center after you've played the move
f3, and after blacks gotten a rook to
e8, so our biggest priority here, apart
from making sure that this pawn remains
healthy, is perhaps an even bigger
priority, is to go Queen d2 and long
castle and get the King to safety, so
that we can focus on operating properly
on the King side, hopefully that makes
sense, okay pawn takes d5, so this
poses us with a dilemma, do not play
Queen takes d5, that drops the Queen to
Bishop takes c3, because that is a
check, we could play Knight takes d5,
and in response I presume that black
wants to play Bishop takes b2, but
there's a move I like even more than
Knight takes d5, this pawn is now an
isolated pawn, technically it's an IQP,
this is not the usual IQP setups that
we tend to get, but it's still an IQP
structure, a pawn on d5 is a serious
weakness, so the move I am very tempted
to play is still Queen to d2, and in
contrast to playing it here, what's the
chief difference, well after Queen d2,
d4 long castle, black doesn't have
another pawn to defend d4 with, and if
black plays there the move Knight to
c6, who can tell me a way in which we
can indirectly reinforce the pressure
on the d4 pawn, I think that move, that
resulting move is super important, and
it's the move Bishop f1 to b5, and the
secondary point of that move is that if
black then takes on e3, we take on d8,
and the Knight on c6 is pinned, so
because of that line I think Queen d2,
it works out tactically, and so it just
makes a lot more sense to me to develop
quickly rather than trying to greedily
capture the pawn and get into tactical
complications after Bishop takes b2,
maybe those complications favor white,
I don't know, but in this speedrun
we're trying to play simple
straightforward chess whenever
possible, so again the line that we had
to calculate is d4, long castle, black
can't take because the Queen hangs, and
Knight c6 is always met with Bishop b5,
okay our opponent develops himself,
Knight e7, I think we continue with our
plan, we long castle anyway, and we
exert additional pressure on the d5
pawn, what you should note here is that
our advantage is not just based on the
weakness of the d5 pawn, it's not like
if we don't win that pawn then the
position is equal, we're also better
from a positional standpoint because we
have control of the square in front of
the pawn, and as you know from previous
discussions of IQP structures, that's
like the first thing that you should be
paying attention to, who's got this
control of the square in front of the
isolated Queen pawn, if it's us then we
can put a Knight on that square, and
that's a pretty juicy Knight, let alone
that in the modern and in the Pirates
white's main plan is to attack the
kingside, presumably black's gonna
castle at some point, and then we're
gonna like full send the pawns down the
kingside, the Bishop on e5 is also
really awkward, it can be targeted with
a well -timed Bishop d4, so we can
further soften up the dark squares on
the kingside, I don't think that we
should rush necessarily with Bishop d4,
I think it's a move we can really play
whenever we want to, so Bishop d4 is a
reasonable alternative, but the move
that I really like here, I think the
positional approach is either to play
Bishop b5 check and then Knight e2, but
even better is I think the immediate
Knight to e2, quickly aiming for d4,
we're trying to plant a Knight on d4,
just to make sure that this pawn
remains immobilized, and the moment
black castles kingside, which hopefully
happens sooner rather than later, we're
gonna send the pawn down and try to
blast open the h -file, and just go for
checkmate, let's go Knight d4, and
establish the Knight on this blockading
square, okay, so what happens if
there's a trade, well generally if
there's an isolated Queen pawn, trades
favor the side that is fighting against
it, and one way to think about that is,
okay, your opponent has finite
resources and finite minor pieces, if
let's say two minor pieces are traded,
then both of blacks remaining two minor
pieces are gonna have to be fully
focused on protecting the isolated
Queen pawn, that means black doesn't
have the resources to allocate to other
things, like let's say defending the
king, okay, so the less pieces there
are, the more valuable the remaining
pieces become, and the less resources
you have to spend on like one
particular task, Queen to d7, okay, so
our opponent keeps the tension, I think
we should also make a move that kind of
keeps the tension, of course we can
already play h4, which is a pretty
helpful move, I mean even if black
stays in the center, opening up the h
-file is still a pretty decent idea, but
I don't think that we should commit to
anything in particular, I think we
should continue accumulating the
pressure in whichever way we can,
there's two ways that I see to do that,
the first is of course the move Bishop
b5, which I think is probably on your
radar, the second is just to play King
to b1, which is a very helpful move,
almost every single time that you
castle Queen side, it's a good idea to
throw in the move King b1, just because
the King is safer on b1 than it is on
c1, I'll get into that in a little bit
more detail after the game, which of
these two moves are we going to decide
on, it's hard to say, it's hard to say
which move is better, I like Bishop b5
because it it pins the Knight and it
takes away the option of Knight takes
d4, but I like King b1 because it's
super flexible, and I really feel like
the King is so much safer on b1 than it
is on c1, there's a concrete line I'm
trying to calculate after Bishop b5,
and I can't tell if it's good or bad
for white, let's go Bishop b5, let's
let's develop the Bishop, let's develop
the Bishop, and obviously from a
practical time management standpoint,
you know, these dilemmas you normally
don't want to spend too much time on,
because chances are, right, if you use
your intuition, chances are this is not
going to decide the game, the decision
that you make at this point is not
going to decide the game, because you
know, approximately likelihood is that
both of these moves are about the same,
maybe one is a little more accurate
than the other, but you don't want to
spend five, six minutes making these
minuscule decisions, right, you just
have to have the executive judgment to
know when to spend a lot of time on a
critical moment, and when there are two
moves that do similar things and that
are similar in nature, you don't want
to spend most of the time like more
than, you know, maybe a minute or two
in a 15 minute game.
Castle's queenside, that was on my
radar, I didn't take this move too
seriously because it felt like Black's
King is so flimsy with the c -file open
and with Black's pawn cover already
ruined, this just felt pretty brazen,
but I guess it makes sense, I mean, the
King is safer here than it is in the
center, but it should be pointed out
that we don't have any obvious
checkmating procedure, there's no way
for us to launch a direct attack
against Black's King, I think our
general strategy here just has to be a
couple of moves that improve our
position, right, we have to accumulate
and accumulate and eventually something
is going to be there I trust in the
center, let's start with the move King
b1, let's just get this out of the way
so that we don't have to think about it
in the future, let's go King b1, and
maybe we could have won a pawn, now
that I'm looking at this, we could have
maybe taken the Bishop on e6 and then
played Bishop takes a7, but I don't
know if I want to part ways with this
juicy knight on d4, our opponent does
the same, King b8, great, okay, now
let's continue playing positionally,
and what playing positionally often
means, not only just like improving
your position, but also trading off
your opponent's strongest piece, or
strongest pieces, to me the Bishop on
e5 is one of the pieces that sort of,
it's a glue piece, it holds Black's
position together, it controls a lot of
critical squares, so the moment the
King moves to b8, it's aligned with the
Bishop, there is a move I'm thinking
about, and we're gonna play this move
because it has no downside, not f4, not
f4, f4 merely chases the Bishop back to
its home square, it does the same thing
on g7 that it does on e5, in fact I
would say it's even safer on g7, rather
than chasing the Bishop away, let's
trade the Bishop off with Bishop to f4,
so the tactics work out for us, Knight
takes d4 is not even possible because
the Knight is pinned, and so is the
Bishop, so Black can't take the Knight
on d4, if Black plays the move f6 and
tries to e6, loses its supporter, and
that wasn't palatable either, okay, we
traded the Bishops, we're making some
progress, we've got a very pleasant
position, and we just need to continue
accumulating the pressure, right, at
this level, a lot of games are won
exactly in this way, you just make
improving moves and improving moves,
and eventually of course, you're gonna
have to transform your advantage into
something tangible, but as long as
there are obvious improving moves, you
want to continue making them, and one
of them is just to bring the Rook to
e1, this is a move everybody should see
and understand, you're just bringing
the Rook to an open file, nothing
extraordinary, putting pressure on the
Bishop, and in these types of
positions, you have to constantly keep
generating and coming up with new ways
to improve your position, your
opponent's turn is a great time to do
that, because on your turn, you know,
you're thinking a little bit more
concretely about what to do, so what
are some ways that we can accumulate
even further pressure on Black's position?
Well, I was gonna say Queen to f6, but
we're faced with a new challenge, Queen
to d6, okay, so let me think about this
for a hot second, I think we have some
tactics, I think we have a perfect
opportunity to take the positional
advantage and transform it into
something more tactical, this is an
advanced concept, this is an advanced
procedure, I'm not gonna pretend that
this is elementary, it's not, how did I
find this?
Well, one of the things I noticed is
that after the Queen trade, there is an
alignment of the Rooks, okay, everybody
should see this, the Rook on d1 and the
Rook on d6 are on open files, the Rook
on d6 is also undefended, so we have a
procedure that first and foremost opens
up the d file, so first and foremost,
we take the Bishop on e6, very
importantly, this move defends the
Queen, right, otherwise we would just
be blundering the Queen, now from a
positional standpoint, this is a
counterproductive move, because we're
actually rectifying Black's pawn
structure on in the center, but what
we're actually doing is we're shifting
the focus from the d file to the e
file, you can think of this as creating
a new weakness, shifting Black's main
weakness from d5 to e6, which is now an
isolated pawn, and it's targeted by the
White Rook, now we trade Queens to get
Black's Rook onto the most exposed
square possible, and hopefully you see
where this is going, the Rooks are
staring at each other, the pawn on e6
is weak, it's defended only by the Rook
on d6, and the crucial move is Knight
to e4, hitting the Rook using tactics
to force the Rook back to either d7 or
d8, and then the final step is going to
be to launch a frontal attack on the
pawn on e6, there's more tactics that
make this work, if Black plays Rook to
d8, you can't play Rook takes e6, the
Rook can't jump over the Knight, and
the Knight is also hanging, now that
the Rook is on a defended square, where
do we go with the Knight?
You need to be very accurate here, you
need to be very, very accurate here, if
you play the tempting Knight to c5,
some of you might be thinking of this
move, Black can actually push the pawn
to e5, remember that is a way that your
opponent can defend a pawn that's
attacked more than once and defended
zero times, you can actually push the
pawn and put it on a new square, no,
you need to go Knight to g5, because
you need to pose a double attack, this
is a double attack, it's a double
attack in the literal sense, we're
attacking the pawn twice, but it's also
a double attack in the more classic
sense, because we're posing a second
threat, we're threatening Knight f7,
forking the Rooks, and Black presumably
is going to defend the f7 square or
move one of the Rooks, and then we're
gonna win the pawn on e6, and once the
pawn on e6 collapses, likely so will
the pawn on d5, that pawn is gonna lose
its supporter, and we're gonna go after
that pawn next, so we're gonna try to
win in the end two pawns in the
endgame, and I'll expand a little bit
on how exactly I found this idea after
the game, largely this was pattern
recognition, it's not like I actually
went through, you know, a five -minute
logical process and made observations,
I saw this kind of instinctively, but
this is what I try to do in the
speedrun, to kind of translate my
subconscious thoughts into a conscious
series of steps that you can follow to
find a similar idea in your game.
Alright, so I'm assuming our opponent's
gonna move one of the Rooks somewhere,
yeah, the fact that our opponent is
investing like four or five minutes now
on this move tells us all we need to
know, Rook c8, that's a good move, I
think that's the best move, it's the
lesser evil, now we need to quickly
decide what are we going to take on e6
with, it's not a given that we take
with a Knight, that's probably the more
natural move to most of us, but Rook
takes e6, a case a serious case could
be made for taking on e6 with the Rook,
in the sense that it keeps the
immediate pressure on the Knight on e7,
and it does threaten to win a second
pawn, we're actually threatening there
to take on c6, force the Knight to
recapture, and then to take the pawn on
d5, I don't really want to part ways
with my Bishop if I can help it, but it
will be worth paying that price for a
second pawn, what worries me slightly
after Rook takes c6 is a weird move
like Knight f5, and then the other
Knight is threatening to jump into d4,
there's like fork ideas, and in the
interest of time, I'm also trying to
play in a way that corresponds with the
amount of time we have left, Knight
takes c6 is just a simpler move to
handle, right, generally in the endgame
you want your Rooks operating from a
distance, you don't want them on the
front lines because they start, you
know what I'm talking about, right,
when you have a Rook that's battling
minor pieces at close quarters, I have
a million examples of this, there's
more tactics, there are more forks, and
you run the risk of, you know, walking
into something like an ill -timed Knight d4.
What about Knight f7?
Knight f7 is reasonable, but I didn't
see the point of that, okay, a6, where
does our Bishop go?
Well, our main priority is to attack
the d5 pawn, the moment you tell this
to yourself, the move should become
very obvious, you have to play Bishop
a4 because the Bishop can later drop
back to b3 and exert direct pressure on d5.
Yeah, Bishop a4, Bishop b3 is just an
El Classico kind of maneuver.
What's great about the placement of the
Knight on e6 is that it's also
controlling the d8 square, so on top of
everything else that Black is
experiencing, he can't put a Rook on
d8, the Knights are totally immobilized
as well, we're attacking d5 so the
other Knight can't move, the Knight
from c6 can move, where will it go?
Its mobility in the center is greatly
restricted, Black can barely move here.
You might be sitting there with the
white pieces thinking, man, like, I
don't know if I'll be able to convert
this, I'm getting nervous, but if you
put yourself in your opponent's shoes,
Black literally is just like out of
moves, so however nervous you might
feel, it's generally going to be
infinitely more difficult to be your
opponent in these types of situations
than it is to be the side that converts
the advantage.
Another good move to just throw in, if
we have the time, and we certainly have
the time, not because Black has no
counterplays, is just to make some lift.
We can do that with the move c3, which
kills two birds with one stone.
It also fully immobilizes the d5 pawn,
making sure that d4 isn't going to
happen, it's harder to shoot at a
moving target, or of course we can play
the more straightforward a3.
And if we had like 30 seconds at this
point, I would definitely play a3, right?
The less time you have, the more you
have to ensure yourself against the
possibility of some freak tactic that
you might not have the time to see.
So if this was a bullet game, I would
definitely be playing a3 on the next move.
Now how do I know that we should play a
move like a3?
Well, it's all about whether or not
your opponent has counterplay, right?
Does your opponent have a clear path
that he can follow in order to generate counterplay?
If the answer is yes, then you're
generally in a bit more of a hurry.
Here the answer is no, because black
has no squares for any of their pieces.
They should back to b3.
Okay, that's where we wanted to go
anyway, but there was nothing better.
Rook e8 is a good move.
That's a tricky move, because if we
take on d5, then black will recapture
with the knight, we take with the rook,
and our knight on e6 there is a little
bit awkward, right?
Because it's pinned to the rook on e1
that's going to lose its defender.
So I don't want anything to have to do
with bishop takes d5.
There's no rush.
That pawn isn't going anywhere at all.
So let's focus on improving our
position such that when we take the
pawn, we won't have to deal with a
fallout, and we won't have to rely on
tactics to get our knight out of e6.
The move that I mentioned earlier, I
think it's a perfect time to play it.
Let's go c3.
Wait, actually let me think about this
for a second, because c3 maybe he's got
knight a5.
Oh, but then we've got knight g7.
That's beautiful.
C3.
Yeah, I love the move c3, because
another thing to notice, and you notice
these things by avoiding tunnel vision, right?
It's easy to tunnel in on the d5 pawn
and forget that there are other tactics
that could have nothing to do with the
pawn on c5.
Anytime there's contact between pieces,
you have to notice that the rook on e1
is not making direct contact with the
knight on e7, but it could be making
direct contact after a certain
something move.
So we're just going to take on b4, and
I played that move quickly to lure my
opponent into recapturing quickly,
which I think he might have smelled a
rat, but at this point it's too late.
No, he didn't.
And by not tunnel visioning, you are
going to be able to find a move that
wins on the spot.
Now the knight on e7 is what we call a
type two undefended piece.
It's only protected by one other piece.
If you can dislodge that rook from e8,
well then likely you're going to win
the knight on e7, because the rook
can't maintain contact with the knight.
There's no ninth rank.
What's the move?
It's not bishop a4.
I tricked you.
Some of you might say, oh, it's bishop a4.
No, because then the rook moves, and
the white rook can't jump over the knight.
You need to do two things at once.
You need to move the knight away and
attack the rook.
Can you do that?
You absolutely can, and that's the move
knight g7, fianchettoing the knight,
and that ends the game.
That ends the game.
Yeah, knight g7 is one of those like
geometric moves that can be hard to
spot, because your brain doesn't often
associate like the g7 square for your
opponent with like a knight being
there, but the more concrete your
thinking, the more specifically you
formulate questions to yourself, the
likelier it is that you see a
relatively unorthodox tactic, and
obviously like making observations does
not guarantee that you will find a tactic.
It raises the probability that you see
stuff, and it raises the amount of
things that you see.
So by not tunneling in on the d5 pawn,
we were able to find this move.
If we had tunneled in on the d5 pawn,
we would have certainly played the move a3.
That is the move I would play if I was
just obsessed with winning this pawn.
I'd say, oh, well, let's get knight out
of b4, and then let's take the pawn.
Obviously knight g7 is quite a bit sexier.
Let's take the rook, and what's ironic
is that now the second idea comes into play.
This is awesome.
First, we win one rook by playing
knight g7.
Now we can try to win the second one by
playing the move that some of you
wanted to play initially.
Now it's time for bishop to a4.
I love that the bishop dropped back to
b3 in order to attack d5, and now moves
up again to a4, where it encounters
greener pastures.
The game is over.
If black blocks with knight c6, we of
course simply take the knight, and then
we take on e8, and the opening
experiment was a success.
So as we get into the analysis, once
again, the link to my Jebaba London
course is going to be in the
description of this video, as is going
to be the link to a preview video that
tells you all you need to know about
the course.
But in this game, it was not meant to
be, and we deviated on move one.
Of course, after d4, black is not
obliged to play the moves d5 or knight f6.
That's what you're going to face 90 % of
the time, but you have to have
responses prepared against some of the
other moves in this position.
I'm talking f5, e6, b6, and you can
learn most of those in a couple of well
-allocated days.
The Jebaba London itself happens after
knight f6, knight c3, d5, and bishop f4.
This is the starting position of the course.
Okay, so in this game, we faced the
move g6.
This is, of course, the modern defense,
and I would call this the close sibling
of the Pirates.
The Pirates, or the Pirque, as some of
us call it, is d6, of course.
White plays generally e4, knight f6,
knight c3, and g6.
The modern is, I think, called that
because black delays the development of
the knight, and this is a somewhat
cagier version of the Pirates.
You might say, well, what's the utility
of delaying the move knight f6?
Well, by delaying this move, black
opens up more possibilities for themselves.
So, for example, after e4, bishop g7,
knight c3, okay, our opponent played
the Gorgonidze.
That's one thing you can't really do
with the Pirates because you already
have a pawn on d6.
So, this is one thing.
Another very common continuation that's
unique to the modern, after d6, I was
planning to play f4 and go into the
Austrian attack.
Here, you can transpose into the
Pirates with knight f6, but you can
also play a move that, I think, is
sometimes known as Tiger's Modern,
named after a Swedish GM, Tiger Hillar Persson.
If you're interested in exploring this
line from black's perspective, he wrote
a book called Tiger's Modern that I've
heard really good things about.
So, this is a serious opening for black.
The reason I don't recommend it at all
to anybody under, say, 2200 is because
you need to know reams of opening
theory, and you need to know it in
order to avoid getting completely crushed.
So, this opening guarantees,
essentially, that you will have winning
chances, but it also guarantees that
you have quite a few losing chances.
So, I won't talk about a6 here because
we have plenty to discuss in the
context of the Gurgonidze.
So, c6 enters the Gurgonidze.
I actually am curious whether
Gurgonidze was the first player to play
the move c6.
I'm going to bet no, and I'm going to
ask you guys a trivia question.
Let's say the question is as follows.
Do we think that this position occurred
for the first time before 1900 or after 1900?
I have a guess, but I'm curious what
people think.
When did this position first occur in
tournament practice?
And if you're watching on YouTube, you
can try to make a guess.
Yeah, we're pretty much split down the middle.
I'm going to guess after.
I'm going to guess 1940.
Let's see.
And the answer is 1953.
And oh, and this is cool.
It was first played by Genrik
Kasparian, who was an international
master from Armenia, and he's more well
known as a study composer.
He's a super famous study composer, and
studies are invented chess positions
that serve as really beautiful chess puzzles.
He was the first person to play this.
Gurgonidze, I see his name, but he was
maybe like the 10th or 11th player to
play this move in 1968, 15 years later.
Igor Zaitsev was the third person to
play this.
He was Anatoly Karpov's second and one
of his most loyal assistants, also a grandmaster.
It's really interesting to see how
these openings start to acquire popularity.
Anyways, the main line, of course, is
still to play f4.
Black responds with d5.
And you might look at this and say,
well, this looks like Black's Bishop is
terrible, but what Black has
accomplished by playing this kind of
cross between the modern and the
Karukhan is that Black has carved out
these light squares on the king side.
You guys should see how, well, first of
all, the f5 square, the g4 square, the
e4 square, there's a kind of a complex
of weak light squares, and Black can
orient his play around those light squares.
That is why you see Black playing h5.
This is the main move.
It is intended to prevent g4 and to
secure the f5 square for the Bishop.
If you play Bishop f5 immediately, you
walk right into g4.
After h5, White generally responds with
Knight f3, and the Black Knight is
developed to h6.
If you understand the high -level
approach, these moves should not be a
mystery to the Knight.
Where is it going?
Well, it's going to one of these weak
light squares.
And if White is not well -versed in this
structure, White can get a really bad
position really fast.
What's an example of that?
Well, a lot of people, they play the
move h3 because they kind of want to
prepare g4.
If you play this move prematurely,
you're actually creating even more
weaknesses on the king side, because
you can't easily play g4.
Of course, here, no.
Here, the rook hangs on h1.
But if you don't play g4, if you make,
you know, a random developing move, who
can tell me a typical move?
You see this often in the Gurganidze
that essentially prevents g4 once and
for all.
And this is a worthy move to know.
This also occurs very often in the
King's Indian.
This exact idea is common in the King's
Indian from Black's side.
I'm talking about the move h4.
How does this permanently prevent g4?
Well, obviously, Black has en passant.
And in order to start surrounding this
pawn, White has to give away the light
squared bishop.
Now, these squares are even weaker, and
Black has the bishop pair.
So, you can definitely explore some of
the Gurganidze on your own.
And from a computer standpoint, if you
turn on the engine, the engine most of
the time, depending on which engine,
Stockfish, I think, does recommend the
move f4.
And White is better.
If White handles this position very
accurately, White is definitely better.
But in this game, I wanted to choose
something a little bit more practical.
Let me show you how this is similar to
the King's Indian.
In the King's Indian, in many lines,
you get a situation, d6.
Let's go down the Petrosian variation,
which is an early d5, just as an example.
So, you often get this type of situation.
The knight gets to c5, and it exerts
pressure on e4.
So, now you play a5.
You've probably seen me do this a
million times.
You do that to prevent b4.
And a lot of players who are newer to
the King's Indian, from the White side,
they tend to play the move a3,
thinking, well, I'm just going to play
b4 in one fell swoop.
And of course, you run into a4.
This is a very nasty construction,
because White can basically never play
the move b4.
And on top of that, Black gets a really
nice outpost for the knight, and then
Black can solidify the a4 pawn with the
move, bishop to d7.
So, again and again, as you get to a
higher level, as you gain rating, this
is worthwhile to do, to see
similarities between openings that you
play and openings that you see in high
-level chess.
That way, you build a more
comprehensive picture of chess as a whole.
And the higher rated you are, the wider
and broader your chess education and
your chess knowledge has to be, because
you're going to get more and more
diverse types of positions out of the
opening, because people are going to be
playing different stuff.
They're going to know it.
And so, it pays to be familiar with
different types of structures and
different types of ideas across many openings.
Okay, so after c6, we decided on bishop
e3, and we decide to build up the pawn
chain with the move f3.
So, a little bit of theoretical overview.
The most popular move in this position
for Black is d takes e4.
This, I believe, is not the correct move.
It's the move, I think, that you will
face very, very often.
And after pawn takes e4, it is common
for Black to counter -strike in the
center with e5.
But after e5, Black is clearly worse.
White takes on e5, and generally, Black
trades queens here.
If Black takes on e5 right away, well,
this is even worse version, because
here, you can trade queens on your own
and get your knight out.
And you just get an overwhelming
development advantage in this type of position.
I mean, just look at this, bishop c4,
castle queenside.
It's already plus three.
This is out of the question.
So, most of the time, Black takes the
queen, White takes back.
And here, I've had this position
against Hikaru quite a few times.
Bishop takes e5 is a mistake, because
it walks right into knight f3.
10 games in the database, and Black is
in massive, massive trouble.
Bishop g7, bishop comes out to c4.
And there's tactics galore on all sides
of the board.
After something like knight d7, White castles.
Look at the pressure on the f -file here.
Black can't get their pieces out at all.
Knight gf6 walks into e5.
2342 had this position in 2009.
Knight g4.
And now, after bishop to d4, that's how
the game continued.
Let me see how the game continued.
Yeah.
Oh, White didn't play e5.
In the game, White didn't play e5.
This position is completely and utterly
lost for Black.
If Black plays knight takes e5, then
you can play knight e5, bishop e5.
And who can spot the killer blow in
this position?
Why does a move that ends the game immediately?
This is a trick question, ladies and gentlemen.
So, take a little bit of time here.
Be careful.
But just me saying that it's a trick
question should lead you to suspect
that rook e1 is not the best move.
Black defends the knight with f6.
White is still winning.
But more accurate is bishop takes f7 check.
Simple tactics, takes takes, rook g8,
and White ends the game with rook e1
winning all of Black's pieces.
If Black plays king e7, this is
literally checkmate.
Hello.
So, bishop takes e5 just gives White
this overwhelming lead in development.
Instead, the best move is knight d7.
Hikaru has played this move.
He's also played bishop e5 against me
and won, I'm pretty sure.
So here, there is a very important
concept, a move that forces Black to
ruin his own structure as well.
This is incredibly common.
Whenever you have a pawn that is
condemned, this pawn is condemned, right?
You're going to lose it anyway.
Well, you don't give it away without a fight.
You don't give it away without forcing
some concessions.
And so, the best move here is to play
e6, f takes e6.
And according to my analysis, White
just needs to play solid positional chess.
It's plus over minus.
It's like 0 .8 in favor of White here.
And it's not surprising.
White has better development.
The pawn on e6 is much weaker than its counterpart.
And if Black just proceeds
nonchalantly, you're going to plant the
dark squared bishop on d4 in order to
neutralize its counterpart on g7.
Let's say Black, I don't know, let's
say Black castles.
Of course, bishop c4.
Of course, knight g5.
The position plays itself, and I don't
say that lightly.
White's got fantastic chances in a
position like this.
What else is there?
So in this position, I think that's
basically it.
I mean, Black can also play bishop to
e6 in order to try to prevent White
from playing pawn to e6.
But here, of course, you don't give
away the pawn.
Here, the loss of a tempo means that
White will cling to this pawn on e5,
which makes it very difficult for Black
to develop their knight to a good spot.
Remember that h6 is almost always met
here with the move h4.
You want to prevent kingside expansion
with g5.
So this is one of the biggest draws of
this line.
A lot of people go into this endgame,
and it's just virtually unplayable from
a practical standpoint.
Knight to f6 is the other move that you
should be familiar with in this position.
White, of course, responds with a
developing move of our own.
And if Black plays knight to g4, as
scary as this move looks, it's really
not a big deal.
And okay, there's many things that you
can do here.
I like the simple bishop up to f4.
And generally, Black, again, plays the
move e5.
If Black just continues to develop,
well, you're going to play h3.
You're going to bring your queen up to d2.
And I mean, look at White's incredible
center and White's attacking prospects
on the kingside are delicious.
So I'm seeing a game in the database
that went b5.
Just a moment.
I'm seeing a game that went b5.
And White can play something like the
engine likes e5, knight to d5, and
bishop to h6, getting rid of Black's
dark squared bishop.
Then you're going to play h4, h5, hg,
and there will be hell to pay for Black.
So this is very one -sided.
After bishop f4, Black should play e5.
And here we reach a slightly better
version of this endgame for Black, but
White is still better.
Takes, takes, knight to d7, we play e6,
f takes e6, and you can play a move
like bishop to e2.
Okay?
And after Black castles, the engine
actually likes keeping this bishop on
this diagonal because there are some
important squares on it.
You don't want to go bishop g3 and walk
into knight e3, right?
So you want to keep the bishop here.
You're going to castle.
You're going to enjoy your life in an
endgame like this.
So that's an overview of pawn takes e4.
Other moves aren't really worth talking
about other than the best move, which
is queen to b6.
I'll get to it in a moment.
If Black plays knight f6, you get like
a much improved version of the
Gorgonese because here, the knight
can't easily get to f5.
So this position just sucks for Black.
And you don't have to play f4, but I
think this makes sense.
And then you're going to go knight f3,
and potentially you're just going to go
like h4 and blast through on the king side.
So the best move, and the move that not
a lot of people know at an intermediate
level, is queen to b6.
I had a game here, a classical game,
against Alex Lenderman, who was a top
American GM in 2011, which I managed to win.
And the best move for White is just to
ignore the threat on b2 and play the
move queen to d2.
Black has to know to accept the sacrifice.
It's not really a sacrifice because
you're going to win the pawn back.
But as a sales pitch for this line, I
want to show you the start of my game
against Lenderman to show you how
difficult it is to handle this type of
position for Black.
Let me find the game in the database.
Oh no, I'm sorry.
It was slightly different.
It was e4, g6, d4, bishop g7, knight
c3, c6, bishop e3.
And he immediately played the move
queen b6.
And this is a different version.
I played queen d2, so I was almost right.
Takes rook b1, queen a3, knight f3.
And this position is an improved
version for White, because Black can't
play d5 anymore.
That square is now covered twice.
But watch what happened in the
Lenderman game.
He played the move b5 in order to
prevent the bishop from coming out to c4.
Who can tell me how I punished his lack
of development here?
And there's a beautiful detail, a
really nice move that would have
finished the game immediately that I missed.
Here, the move, like, plays itself.
Like, you just can't resist, of course.
It's bishop b5.
And Lenderman saw this.
He accepts my bishop here.
I started to get very excited.
And this is the position that he was
aiming for.
I missed the best move.
I played knight c7.
And after king d8, we had total and
complete chaos.
White, however, is winning on the spot
with an incredible move.
This is really beautiful.
Let's see if anybody can find it.
Pause the video if you're on YouTube.
Maybe take a good, like, three to five
minutes here if you really want to work
your tactical brain.
Not castles.
That's a little slow.
Castles is slow.
No, it's not castles.
You see, if you castle, then Black will
defend the c7 square with knight a6.
And you say, oh, I trapped the queen.
You don't.
The queen has c4.
And that's a hint.
C4 is the only evacuation square that
the queen has.
You got it.
Sardine, you earned a sub.
Or everybody who answered is a sub.
Queen to c3 ends the game immediately.
Because if Black takes with check, you
bring the king up.
Black loses the queen.
Because if he takes, you get checkmated
on c8.
Now, this is a very high -level move.
If Black plays knight to a6 in order to
defend the bishop, you win the game
with the secondary idea.
Rook to a1.
There's no more c4 square.
And queen e6 runs into rook takes a6.
And Black loses everything.
Actually, Black loses the queen because
of knight c7.
Now, the game could last a little bit
longer because Black has a rook and a
piece for the queen.
But it's, like, plus six.
Obviously, White's just crushing.
So this just gives you a sense of how
difficult these positions are to play.
But unfortunately, we're talking here
about a slightly different version.
Here, with the pawn on d5, it's improved.
But after queen takes b2, rook b1,
queen a3.
Actually, I was wrong.
Yeah, because in the Lenderman game, my
knight was on f3.
So that's the main reason this is an
improved version for Black.
Here, you play e takes d5.
And I still maintain that this is a
much easier position to play for White.
But it is equal.
And it's equal if Black knows the move
knight to f6, first of all.
You bring the bishop out, I'm pretty
sure, according to what I looked at.
No, you play d takes c6.
And here, Black has to know another move.
Knight takes c6 is a bad move because
of d5.
And White gets a big initiative.
You have to know the move bc, which is
far from intuitive, I think.
White develops the bishop to d3.
Castles, knight g2.
White is a very compact position.
And again, engine gives equal, but
Black has to know more engine moves
like bishop to a6.
And finally, this position is equal for
obvious reasons.
I mean, Black has good, well -placed
pieces, but so does White.
So it's one of those things.
If your opponent knows all of these
moves, if you watch this video, kudos.
You know, take your hat off.
Sometimes you just have to admit that
your opponent knows everything.
But I don't think that you're going to
face this sequence of moves all that often.
You're going to face knight f6 or pawn
takes e4.
Some people are going to probably go
knight h6, which is really dumb because
of queen d2 sending the knight right
back to g8.
Okay.
So finally, we get to our opponent's
move, which is nothing to sneeze at.
I mean, e5 is a legitimate alternative,
but I'm pretty sure that it hands over
a big initiative and a big advantage
after pawn takes e5.
Okay.
So bishop takes e5.
And we played the move e takes d5,
which is normal according to the computer.
The computer also likes the immediate
bishop to d4, which came across our radar.
I mean, this is not an engine move.
It's a pretty obvious idea.
And according to the computer, forcing
this bishop off the board would give
White a big advantage, like plus 1 .5.
And in my move, it's around plus 0 .8.
So it's not a mistake, but bishop d4 is
even more accurate.
What was I worried about here?
I thought that Black would go here.
But apparently, after you trade, you
just go queen d2, and White's huge
development advantage gives him just an
overwhelming position.
Wherever Black goes, you're now going
to castle.
Ah.
And Black can't take on e4 because of
the mate.
And if Black castles, then you say,
thank you very much for the pawn.
Takes, takes, takes.
And White is much better.
So bishop d4 would have been best, but
instead, we play d takes d5, which I
think is perfectly suitable.
C takes d5.
And of course, we bring our queen up to d2.
And White has a small -ish but very
stable advantage.
And most importantly, this is a much
easier position to play for White.
So hopefully, that overview was
sensible, and you understood all of the
main ideas.
So here we develop our pieces, 97,
castles, bishop e6.
I think this is quite normal and
obvious without commentary.
The next interesting moment really
occurred after we played 94, Black
played queen d7.
And I feel like Black embarks
fundamentally on the wrong plan.
I just feel like castling queenside
here opens Black up to so many problems
in the center and on the queenside.
I would go so far as to say that at a
title player level, castling queenside
might be close to the decisive mistake.
What would I do instead here for Black?
Well, the move that concerned me the
most was actually a very simple
approach where Black trades off all the
pieces that he can and castles kingside.
And I did mention during the game that
piece trades favor the side that plays
against the IQP.
Well, yes, but here Black has bigger
fish to fry.
In particular, Black wants to avoid
getting checkmated.
And the queen on d4 is not a good
blockader, right?
By trading, you've essentially lured
the queen onto d4 where it can be
susceptible to, of course, the move
knight f5 or to the move knight c6.
And if White plays h4, Black can play
knight c6.
And if we play queen d2, Black can push d4.
And it's quite clear that Black has
generated serious counterplay against
the queenside.
According to the engine, White is still
quite a bit better with knight e4
because queen d5 runs into the fork and
bishop takes a2 is very dubious on
account of the typical b3.
So White is still better.
But Black's position remains quite playable.
Maybe this is a better option after
queen d2, d4.
Here, this comes with far greater
effect because the knight can get into e3.
So something like this, I think, would
have given Black a defensible position
after queen d7, bishop b5, long castle.
And king b1 is maybe less to the point
than a move like rook he1.
But I just wanted to illustrate how
pleasant positions like this are to
play and how you really just need to
kind of enjoy positions like this.
And moves like king b1 signify that
you're not in any massive hurry to do
something crazy.
Just make these improving moves, and
you will notice how your opponent often
just collapses on their own.
King b8, and now a very important move,
bishop f4, trading off our opponent's
strongest piece.
Was this the only move?
No.
Probably the computer would prefer
something more straightforward like
rook he1.
But it's a very sensible move because
we are leaving Black with a terrible
bishop on e6 that's essentially just a
big pawn.
So bishop f4, queen f4, and I think
another mistake is the move king a8.
I think queen c7 should have been
preferred, essentially forcing our hand.
Our opponent gave us too many free moves.
He let us bring all our pieces to great squares.
I mean, it's no surprise then that we
had a game -winning tactic.
Literally all of our pieces are located
on perfect squares.
When that is the case, you just
automatically need to search for tactics.
If you're looking at your position,
you're saying, wait a second,
everything is placed perfectly.
It's all staring at crucial files and weaknesses.
You better start looking for tactics.
Okay, so queen c7, I think, was Black's
last chance to attain a defensible position.
I might even have taken on c7 and taken
on c6, something like this.
The engine actually likes this because
after bc, rook he1, again, Black is
under tremendous pressure on the e
-file, and rook to d6 is possible, but
now we can target the square on c5.
Whenever you have a structure that
involves hanging pawns on c6 and d5,
your sort of traditional textbook plan
involves what I call the Rubinstein
maneuver, and I've named it after Akiba
Rubinstein, who demonstrated a perfect
way to play against this pawn chain, c6
and d5.
What idea am I talking about?
What square are we trying to occupy,
and with what piece, and for what purpose?
But if you want, you can just name the square.
So don't touch the knight on d4.
It's perfect.
The knight on d4 is serving an
important purpose, but the other knight
is unemployed, and we want to go knight
a4 and knight c5.
By occupying the second blockading
square, we're completely immobilizing
this pawn chain.
It's the same principle as occupying
the d4 or d5 square when one side has
an IQP.
Here is a very quick run through of the
Rubinstein game that I'm talking about.
Thing is, these two players, Rubinstein
and his opponent was Georg Salve, who
was one of the top players of that time.
Yeah, basically what happened in this
game was a situation in which Black got
that structure, okay, and White did
exactly what we just discussed.
White brings his pieces out, knight a4,
there it is, and White piles up on the
c5 square with everything that he's got.
Rook c1, bishop c5, there it is, and
everything is all about the c5 square.
By keeping this square under control,
you're ensuring that c6 remains a
weakness forever, and watch what
Rubinstein does.
Bishop f1, e3, get the knight to c5,
blockade the square, bring the rook to
c2, b4, fully ensconcing the rook on
c5, and eventually Rubinstein has some tactics.
The rule applies here as well.
In this position, all of Rubinstein's
pieces are in perfect squares.
The bishop, the rook, the queen, the
other rook, and guess what?
There is a tactic that involves rook
takes c6 and queen takes a7.
At one moment, I'll invest more time in
this game because there's a lot to talk
about, but for those watching on
YouTube, this has been a six -hour
stream, and I'm basically exhausted
already, so I'm going to leave that for
another occasion.
And the final thing to discuss is how
exactly we saw 96 and 94, because after
this move, I think everything was
incredibly straightforward.
Once we win the spawn, the game is
over, let's be real.
But how do you find moves like this?
Well, one piece of advice is everything
is placed perfectly, look for tactics,
but the other things I mentioned during
the game.
There's contact on the d -file between
the rooks.
Any contact between heavy pieces is
automatically a source of tactics,
particularly because the rook on d6 is undefended.
The other thing to remember is that you
should not get fixated on maintaining
one particular pawn structure.
You should not be afraid to alter the
pawn structure your opponent has in
order to shift the object of attack
from one file to another, and this is
the case here.
You just have to consider this capture
because it's obvious that you want to
go after one of black's pawns.
So seeing these two moves is just a
matter of calculating the stuff that
you're supposed to calculate, and then
seeing 94 is a matter of being aware of
the placement of the rooks, the fact
that the rook on d6 is undefended, and
ultimately 94 should come to mind more
often than not, which is not to say
you're going to see all of these moves,
but when you solve and you go through
this process, you're just trying to
raise the probability that you find
certain things.
Knight g5, knight takes c6, and the
rest I think is very evident without commentary.
We got our bishop back to b3 to attack d5.
We played the very patient move c3, and
then we pounced on the opportunity to
win the knight on e7.
We didn't tunnel vision on the d5 pawn.
This, by the way, I thought was a
little bit more messy because the
knight on e6 is pinned to the rook.
The engine indicates that it's
completely winning with rook e4.
I didn't see this move, but why?
Why bother when we can make a patient
move that keeps all of our advantages
and reserves the right to take on d5
whenever we want to?
Yeah, some of you were asking about
bishop takes d5.
So again, hopefully the object of my
worry is obvious.
I also, for some reason, was a little
concerned about knight d8.
Of course, I missed from a distance
that you have knight c7 check, which is
a simple discovered attack, but if I
had seen rook to e4, I would have
probably gone for this because this is
like concretely unbeatable.
Black can't even go rook e8 because
again there's knight c7, again, and you
win the rook in a different way.
So this is just two pawns up.
Also from the corner of my eye, I
thought maybe this move is going to be
annoying, but you can just drop the
rook back to d2, and then again you can
play rook e4 on the next move.
All right guys, I think everything is clear.
So what we had was a summary of the
theory after f3.
Remember, queen b6 is the best move.
Still doesn't solve all of black's problems.
e5 happened in the game.
D takes e4 is what I spent the most
time on.
Then we could have played bishop d4 in
this to immediately target black's
strongest piece.
This was a sub -theme of the game,
targeting your opponent's strongest pieces.
The other main theme was patience, right?
This game was all about patience.
It started here, where knight takes d5,
super impatient move, would allow
either a big lead in development or
chaos after bishop takes b2, neither of
which we want.
So we patiently develop our queenside.
Then patience in this part of the game
where we just bring our pieces and put
them on good squares because we have
the time to do that.
Trading off your opponent's strongest
piece, rook he1, and then tactical
awareness at the right moments, right?
Understanding that when everything is
well placed, you're likely to have some
way to convert the positional advantage
into something more tactical.
That's what I was able to do by
bringing the knight to g5, winning the
pawn, and the technical phase of the
game was very straightforward.
Thanks for hanging out, everybody!